how you doing how does it feel to be at
an award show where you've already won
she could have no words show knowing
that you've already won but yeah it's
great I'm really proud of the film and
anytime we can shine it shine a
spotlight on the film that you like it's
it's a great opportunity so I loved this
film I started watching it just
captivated from start to finish also
loved you as a protective father all
right
entering the the the last phase of my
career concerned dad man no what was the
biggest challenge about doing that role
though where you're kind of confined to
that that computers yeah I mean the lack
of other actors you know it's the most
helpful thing in a performance is to
have another good actor to play off of
and things happen and you know so when
you don't have that other set of eyes
it's it's just very challenging him was
was a difficult one to navigate I was
constantly just going did we good with
that right because I had very little
feel for it
right so was that one of those unique
things where you actually go to the
screening or like I have no idea how
this is gonna look it really was like I
just wondered if it would all work I
mean it was there on the page and I felt
confident about the work we did that day
but the format was so different I just
didn't know how it would all come
together and you know if you think about
all the graphics that they had to create
there's a world in which that sucks you
know that it's not convincing and that
was one of the great things about the
film that they just sort of represented
screen life so accurately yeah and if it
wasn't accurate I don't think the movie
works you know so yeah you're right I
didn't know whether what what I would
see when I went in right it wasn't like
my face space or whatever yeah you have
something very excited coming up you're
in an episode of The Twilight Zone
Jordan Peele swalot zone can you tell me
about working with him getting that call
yeah I'm I was a fan of the
show I'm 86 years old and so I had seen
the but I grew up on those shows and
there it's sort of missing from that
particular vibe is missing from American
culture right now on television as much
as we have right now we don't have that
right so it's really excited for that to
come back and I want to be a part of it
and of course with Jordan and helming I
just thought that the tone would be
right on and it really does Hugh I can
tell you it used to the original and
it's almost like it's almost like a
campfire story those those old Twilight
zones it's almost like somebody's
telling you I don't excuse me a story
versus reading it or something so I was
really excited to be part of it I'm so
excited for it and lastly Star Trek for
what's going on are we still optimistic
it's ever gonna happen we're hearing it
show I certainly I'm down and you know
to be honest I mean it's not happening
right now as far as I know but I just
think it will happen it's somebody at
some point we'll all get on the same
page and we'll do it because it's just
um I mean that's my belief
maybe I'm being optimistic but yeah okay
all those how could I make that actor's
life but uh but yeah I think so it's
just it really to me it's a really
significant part of American popular
culture I just don't see how it goes
away forever yeah
so much thank you talk to you
[Music]